hello everyone and welcome to a
spectacular puzzle that I found while
browsing Twitter it was uploaded by
David Lada and if you uh look at the
date he uploaded it on February 14th
2021 he uploaded it on Valentine's Day
that's just how much he loves chess and
once you see this you guys will love it
as well uh you will immediately want to
share it with everyone especially with
your good friends at the bar in the
library and um yeah sorry about no
videos for the past few days I
celebrated my uh 36th birthday and it
was you know very enjoyable we had some
friends over we made some pizzas had
some beer and now I'm returning with uh
well with this beautiful puzzle so I
hope you guys don't mind uh I really
think you're gonna enjoy this one and uh
yeah that's pretty much it as usual
Agate matter that is myself playing with
the black pieces he's facing Mr hoodie
guy who always has the white pieces and
puzzles and he always wins uh as you can
see there's quite a bit of a rating
difference uh there so you know not not
not great for me how about what you're
gonna do feel free to pause the video
and find a winning idea for white here
it's some say it's an incredibly easy
puzzle some say it's it's too difficult
to solve uh what do you guys think give
it give it a uh you know a few seconds
or a minute if you have an hour uh
however you know doesn't matter how much
you you want to invest uh you can even
check it out pause the video and then
come back in a week let's say it all
depends on how you roll uh but let's uh
let's try and solve this puzzle
uh so for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations uh you you know in
order to solve this you really have to
see some 10 moves ahead but as usual
with every puzzle only the first move
matters uh and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show uh the solution
to this puzzle is Queen to f8 with check
and now uh okay now it probably is uh
are thinking how does this even work
well the problem is uh how do you how do
you get out of stalemate that's the
that's the real problem with this puzzle
if you play a slow move let's say queen
t7 you want to play E8 Queen on the next
d8 Queen on the next move uh then you
run to the Rook captures on H1 check and
once you block a real captures anyone
will be Checkmate so of course you
cannot play a slow move like Queen D7 it
has to be a forcing move uh you might
think okay can't we just capture on B3
and then we don't care about stalemate
um uh now you actually do have to care
about stalemate because the queen takes
away the B3 Square from the white king
now you run into Rook captures on H1
King to A2 and not Rook the A1 with
check and the only is to capture the
road because the queen is preventing the
king from reaching B3 King captures an
A1 and it is still made as the white
Pawn prevents the uh or rather the white
pawns are preventing the black king from
moving and even if you uh after this
check you first play Queen to D1 doesn't
really matter Rook capture Sandy one
with Chuck King A2 and now the Rook is
nicely covering the d8 square you don't
have to worry about that pawn ever
promoting and there's really not all
that much you can do okay a black can
cannot win this game but white cannot
win this game either so that's the
problem with this and if you play uh
another slow move let's say you play
Knights to G3 it's the same problem Rook
to H1 with check forces you to capture
and that's it Knight captures on H1 is
uh stalemate and of course you play
Knight to F1 to block then real
characters and each one and F1 is
Checkmate so that doesn't work however
after Queen the f8 with check you might
think but what's uh the reason for this
I mean black will just do the exact same
thing that's just it black cannot do the
exact same thing because after Rook
capture Santa Fe which is the only move
for black now you have Knight to F2 and
now yes black can capture the Knight but
it will not come with check the Knight
is preventing at The Rook from coming
all the way to F1 and now of course if
you capture then white will just play
Pawn to d8 and bring a queen or Rook
into the game and deliver Checkmate so
you might think all right let's not
capture the Knight let's just build Rook
to h8 and then we're gonna play Rook to
H1 regardless of where the Knight is
where we can even sacrifice The Rook
with Rook to H1 Knight takes and it's
against stalemate but now comes Knight
to H3 again white offers the Knight
saying nope you are not touching the
back rank black says all right I go back
Rook to f8 and now you play Knight
therefore and now of course everyone
knows what is happening here we are
going to use all the squares Rook the h8
with check Knight the H5 and The Rook
the f8 again going for Rook to F1 but
now comes Knight to F6 you cannot
capture with the Rook because of d8
Queen and of course Pawn captures runs
into
a beautiful series of moves on the G7
attacks the rook and okay Rook the G8
you are still guarding G8 and d8 but now
now and only now our Good Friend the
King enters the arena King to B1 and now
of course I don't have to tell you what
will happen and the Beautiful Thing is
okay we can just fast forward the the
white king will just go up the board a
black uh doesn't really have any moves
other than Rook the d8 followed by Rook
to Jade and once you hit that seventh
rank now you might be thinking okay
black will now just sacrifice the rook
and it's still stalemate no it's not
because if you sacrifice a via the f8
square then Pawn captures and then a
queen comes into the game which is
Checkmate and if you play real
characters on D7 then white happily
accepts the sacrifice C captures on D7
uh and now it's not stalemate now the C
Pawn can move you will play C6 or C5 and
then white again wins the game so that's
the problem with the G captors on F6
after this uh Knight to F6 move so you
cannot capture with the Rook you cannot
capture with the pawn what else can you
do you could play Rook to d8 or you
could play Rook the age it let's see
what happens after Rook to d8 well you
Force black into a stalemate but not the
good kind the bad kind of stalemate
which is actually a two swung after
Knight's the E8 there is no move you
will have to capture either the pawn we
already uh have seen that it doesn't
work because the C Pawn can then move or
you can capture uh the the Knight there
really isn't anything else you will play
Rook to see it and then of course spawn
characters with Checkmate but after Rook
captures knight uh then of course D
capture 78 bringing a rook or a queen
into the game will result in Checkmate
so that's the problem with Rook to d8
and finally Rook the h8 which is still
uh you know hoping to get that Rook to
H1 check-in now comes the eighth queen
and now you will get this Knight to D7
check move and black is out of options
he has to play real characters on uh d8
Knights the D7 with check only one move
for black and that is to capture the
pawn still prevents the black king from
moving uh Rook captures on D7 the
captures on D7 freeing up the C Pawn to
be able to be pushed forward now you
play C6 or C5 doesn't really matter and
then of course d8 queen that will be
Checkmate so absolutely beautiful
beautiful puzzle I I don't know the
origin of the puzzle who created it I
just know that David Lada posted it on
Valentine's Day three years ago uh so uh
thank you Doug for that thank you for
always uh enjoying chess so much and for
you know just uh trying to improve
everyone's day and it's all again one of
the one of the bigger reasons why why I
use Twitter because you will always find
things like this on Twitter uh there's
just so much chess you know you will you
you will just uh
find a lot and enjoy a lot if for
example you you are in the chess uh so
uh we can really go through it uh really
quickly one more time so Queen the fate
and then uh the the dance of the Knight
commences Rook captures Knight to F2
rookie Knight to H3 Rook f8 Knight to a
four rookie chicken Knights the H5 Rook
Cafe Knights the F6 and I have to Rook
to h8 finally V8 queen or any of the
other lines that we've checked that are
also completely winning for white
captures and now finally Knights the D7
with check and now the Rook can no
longer avoid the Knight it has to be
captured we'll capture spawn captures
frees up the C Pawn so you don't uh
deliver stalemate uh C5 or C6 and then
of course Queen to d8 with the Checkmate
a beautiful puzzle uh I think you once
again David for posting it I haven't
seen it when he posted it in 2021 but
I'm glad I ran into it today as he he
just uh retweeted it so so it popped up
into my feed uh so that's the puzzle
hope you guys enjoyed it like I said
sorry about no videos for the two days
but uh you know uh it was my birthday
and we we took some time off you know uh
we arrested well and now now we are back
in Action uh so yeah once again I really
hope you guys enjoyed it I would like to
thank Andre lucicov Terrence clicker uh
bullet just thriller.com Mark lefkowitz
and Dan McCormick for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here and thank all
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day and do use that hashtag
suggestion as I am I'm always very happy
when you guys suggest good videos see
you soon